as your butt feels are you ready not
really I'm so happy you're here though
I'm gonna hold your bar to go hold your
hand listen I'm Brazilian I was blessed
with a nice bubble butt all my life but
you know over the years so that's the
consent again
okay gravity spares no one darling so I
decided to bring my butt to its previous
Glory I'm getting a Brazilian butt lift
what with age your butt start to Sag a
little I just want to lift a little do
you want to come with me I'm so confused
Julia is a real friend and she always
has my back
how are you good how are you I also
always annoying
nice to meet you nice to meet you lady
you're very cute she came for moral
support
so you are here to have your
non-surgical vbr it is called bloomy
butt lift that they will induce collagen
Productions so the end result is an
argument around them lifted buttocks
with a beautiful silky skin like petals
of a rose oh wow I like petals of a rose
this procedure just moves out and rounds
out my dear I definitely do not want my
ass to look like narcissus how can I
make my booty that juicy can you stop
grabbing my butt okay
oh my gosh now that I dislike her but I
think her butt looks great what bothers
me is the fact that she denies that she
had a butt lift on what have you had
done I've had my nose done
um I've had my lips done but your butt
no just own it ready yeah
I'm just marking the areas of depression
okay little bunny Sensations
[Music]
I hate needles
that's why I don't have botox
[Music]
business
I'm about to faint I literally cannot
take it you okay
I don't think she called the right
friend can you tell me a funny story
instead ouch
tell me a funny story please
what what
baby okay you know we had this romantic
dinner on our dog
walk something up inside both of us and
it definitely brought us closer I'm not
going anywhere you know that I'm happier
okay
I love you more
and Martina knows how much I cannot
comprehend the empty house so Martina
yesterday she comes to me she hugs me
and I'm like what now look at her and
she's like maybe it's time to adopt oh
so sweet I've been wanting to adopt
another child since such a long time but
Martina thought that maybe we both
should move on and do different things
in life I wanted to have more kids and
Martina did not want which is her choice
and I don't go there I'm not standing
yeah you're having a hard time adjusting
to being an empty nester I don't think I
ever will
who would have thought that after me
burning the whole dinner
the outcome would be the happiest in my
life maybe I should burn that fish every
time I cook it but are you sure you want
to start over like you want to like go
back to me it's a continuation drive to
school drop off yes to be honest yes you
still have the energy and the health
to care for another human being and I
absolutely do not want to have
biologically no I would like an older
child yeah that's lovely who
doesn't have
a family to give him love and there are
so many kids in this world that would
die to have new guys as a family yeah
I'm excited
[Music]
amazing